jojo's bizarre adventure penned by
hirohiko araki is one of the most
popular manga on the face of the earth
with a ludicrously popular anime to its
credit however this story and i have a
short but complicated history unlike the
blind one piece review series i created
in 2020 this review is coming not from a
place of enthusiasm but one instead
of hopeful curiosity you see way back
when this show initially grabbed the
world by the scruff of its neck and
whispered lovingly into its ear this is
my swamp
i too along with i assume many of you
decided to see what all the hype
surrounding this show was about
and in my mind i was prepared for a
narrative masterpiece rivaled only by
few with music and animation the likes
of which i had never seen before
such were my naive unjustified
expectations going into this bizarre
adventure
needless to say i gave up towards the
beginning of part 3 but not before
forcing myself to get to that point so
why am i giving this series another shot
you might be asking hope is now that i
have my expectations in check
and i know what to expect i'll be able
to really get into this series and
spoiler alert i think it worked i'm tony
not mark and this is my review for one
of the most bonkers
brash bombastic and bizarre arcs i have
ever had the pleasure to read through
this is part one to jojo's bizarre
adventure
phantom blood
[Music]
dojo
over the last week i posted two polls
onto my twitter at
totally not mark asking my audience how
much of jojo's bizarre adventures manga
have you read and the other asking the
same question regarding the anime the
results were interesting with the vast
majority of people having seen all parts
available in the anime and significantly
more
not having read the month and i view
this as interesting because
ever since i mentioned in my last video
that i was going to be commencing my
jojo series this week
i've been inundated with countless
tweets ranging from polite suggestions
to full-on demands that i watched the
anime for the purpose of this review
and to that i say politely no firstly as
i've mentioned i've already been exposed
to the anime for the first two parts of
the story
and couldn't really get into it secondly
as a reviewer a manga is my preferred
medium of choice to consume story in
this is to help me get as close as
possible to the writer's vision of the
story without any compromise i want to
review
araki the writer of jojo and not some
studio writer or animator paid to
interpret his work
besides plenty have already reviewed the
anime with few reviewing the manga
and let me tell you my experience with
the manga of jojo's bizarre adventure
was
vastly different to my experience with
the anime
explain yourself despite having
technically seen the first two parts in
full i couldn't really remember much
about them at all beyond the main
character's names and some really vague
plot points
dotted here and there and this part one
phantom blood i was particularly fuzzy
on as i personally found it to be
at first the least interesting and at
times
boring and i have no idea what i was
thinking because
boring is not a word i would dare use to
describe phantom blood now with that
said having only seen it in the anime
prior i was quite excited and optimistic
to check this out in my format of choice
manga wait what the anime only had like
eight episodes how is there this much
material to get through for part one all
right look this looks like a lot but if
i'm being honest
now having gone through it while it
seemed long at first it actually turned
out to be
specifically from volume 2 onwards
surprisingly well paneled and paced
in other words phantom blood was
surprisingly fun the slowest part being
its first volume covering the
backstories of the two main characters
or
at least it was initially however when i
understood what i was trying to do in
volume 1
i managed to get into it a lot more
easily however something i have to say
right off the bat regarding the story is
that
bizarre doesn't even begin to scratch
the surface when it comes to describing
what this story is
the way it's told is honestly baffling
not necessarily from a narrative
perspective though i have a lot to
discuss there too
but really more than anything else how
these characters behave and command the
pages of this comic feel as though they
were written and drawn by
an alien that thinks it knows how humans
talk and what they
look like in some cases despite this
however even early on in the story
there's a clear attention to detail
that's present not only with the
characters expressions but also some of
the backgrounds god
these just make me tired to look at
sometimes i mentioned the visuals of
this manga partially because one of the
few aspects that contributed to my
negative experience with the anime was
how little the characters actually moved
i go into an anime to see an animated
story i pick up a manga to read through
the panels of a story and
for me this go around i think the manga
did a much better service to the story
being told here
so let's get to the story the main
characters
the narrative itself tells the story of
the upbringing and ultimate conflict
between
two characters dio brando the antagonist
and jonathan joster the protagonist
otherwise known as jojo and something i
found really interesting right off the
bat was how this story was structured
in addition to the choices made by iraqi
in telling this story
while there are what i would call
narrative flubs dotted throughout this
otherwise simple story it's worth noting
that it's actually a little more
unconventional and dare i say
sophisticated then first impressions
might convince you of it being
lord joestar jojo's father takes deo in
as his adopted son
after his father passes away due to
complications with his health in order
to repay
a debt he owed him immediately it
becomes evident that dio has clear and
malicious motives to gain control of the
joestar fortune in order to prove his
worth
and he will do absolutely anything to
ensure his goals are met
in this story he does some truly
horrific things from kicking jojo's dog
dany to manipulating his friends and
family
and ruining his relationship with his
first love but few instances match up to
the utter cruelty
in this section that presents itself
when deal burns jojo's dog
to death it's an horrific scene and one
this manga really marinates in
there are a number of scenes in this
part where the gruesome nature of the
story is really on full display with
some instances
leaning pretty far into the horror side
of the genre there's a series of
conflicts throughout the years that
build and build and build
leading to the death of jojo's father
and his ultimate life falling into ruin
until the final battle between jojo and
dio which feels fittingly massive in
both scope
and consequence and that's more or less
the plot but what really interested me
early on was how araki ultimately chose
to tell this story you see with a manga
by the name of jojo's bizarre adventure
you'd be forgiven for thinking that this
story would very much follow the
adventures of
jojo and while this is partially true
interestingly this story is split right
down the middle with the first half
focusing on the journey of dio
and the second as a result of that first
journey jonathan's
which makes jonathan in his first half a
supporting character to dio
i'm a what a supporting character now
one issue many might have with this
story early on
i think quite understandably by the way
is that of jonathan's personality and
overall character while his opening
scene is quite strong in establishing
his virtuous good guy persona
his dialogue and subsequent scenes
thereafter feel less heroic and more so
a naive overly dramatic
child which he again quite
understandably is but
normally in these types of stories we
begin by following the hero on a journey
of self-discovery and struggle in order
to achieve his or her goals
however in the first half of this story
jonathan
is 100 reactionary doesn't necessarily
have a goal
and to be perfectly honest is sort of a
goody two-shoes which unless the
character has
agency over the plot can eventually come
off as boring in the first half he
doesn't even really feel like a main
character to me and
in part i think that's because the real
main character of the first half
is dio brando
[Music]
there exists a well-known story writing
concept called the hero's journey
popularized by joseph campbell in his
1949 book entitled the hero with a
thousand faces and
in this book he describes that narrative
pattern as follows
a hero ventures forth from the world of
common day into a region of supernatural
wonder
fabulous forces are there encountered
and decisive victory is won the hero
comes back from this mysterious
adventure with the power to bestow boons
on his fellow men and the degree to
which dio fits into this mold is
too perfect to be coincidental and
what's more is that
throughout the course of this first half
of the story up to its climax
deal the character gives jonathan
joestar the titular character jojo the
narrative circumstances to not only be
the main character of the story but this
time to be compelling complete with new
motivations and a virtuous agency that
guides the plot into finishing its
second and third acts
and while i'm drawing attention to this
second half you'll also notice that
during these sections
dio's contributions to the story
suddenly shift from being the instigator
to being more reactionary and losing
agency as a result he is no longer the
driving force of the plot he's long
since completed his hero's journey and
now jojo is the main character of the
tale leading into the big finish
and i love that aspect of the story for
me this is what helped the pacing during
the midsection that
all too often stories get lost in in
phantom blood's midsection we have the
climax to dio's journey
and we also get the beginning of jojo's
and i thought that was a really clever
idea from the moment the story kicks off
we're introduced to the circumstances
dio has been living in with his father
along with an immediate call to action
he accepts the call and in doing so
casts himself into a new world unlike
anything he's seen before
it's very easy to see at least from the
surface that araki is trying to portray
dio as
an outright villain unapologetic in his
approach to the world and those around
him essentially araki wants
no one to like dio in this story i mean
he beats and burns a dog to death what
more do you need
however over the course of these opening
chapters we gain a host of interesting
and perhaps contradictory insights into
the psyche of dio clearly resentful of
his father
dio is terrified that he will end up
like him a scumbag drunk unable to take
care of himself
or his family and what i found
particularly interesting were the
moments deal would start to remind
himself of his father
how much that would disgust him and what
that might mean for him going forward in
his life
he might not be able to escape who he is
and this acts as a clear motivator for
him to change his circumstances and to
at all costs avoid becoming who his
father was
which just so happened to be accepting
the powers of a mask and becoming a
vampire overlord what's more is
albeit brief there are one or two
instances in the story where we really
get a glimpse into what the primary
reasons behind his father's resentments
might be
he blames him for his mother's death
this was
really interesting to me as throughout
the story dio is painted as one of the
most sadistic characters with the only
fondness he'd ever project
existing for the sole purpose of
manipulating others but
this and i can't believe i'm saying this
about jojo
is actually a really good example of
subtle storytelling that adds more depth
to a character the drawback however
if you can call it that to having a
villain take up so much of your story
specifically early on with almost all of
the agency is that
they become much more interesting than
the hero of unheard
while jonathan does improve dramatically
in my opinion
after the halfway point receiving a
fantastic motivation in avenging his
father and protecting the world from dio
he is from that point on always playing
catch up with the do character
as a result and with the way dio is
framed from the halfway point onward as
this demonic vampire zombie overlord
jonathan needs to overcome it's really
difficult to beat his cool factor also
resulting in for me at least deal
writing his name all
over this part and so while phantomblood
spends an equal amount of time with both
characters overall establishing and
resolving their hero's journeys
after the dust settled i found myself
thinking of dio and not
jonathan when writing about this story
in other words
jonathan becomes an entertaining result
of the world dio
created for himself the second half
with that said regarding jonathan
specifically because his character
really blossoms in the second half i'll
give my final thoughts on him towards
the end
because if there's one thing i want to
make clear with this video
it's that before i gave jojo a second
chance i was
very wrong about jonathan joestar as a
character
and i'll explain more clearly in a
moment but before that
let's discuss the second half in more
detail because holy hell
does this get really good really fast
with my introspective reflection on the
material contained in volume 1 and early
volume 2 i was able to see and
appreciate what araki was trying to do
but
once the second half of the story came
around it's like everything started to
fall into place for me whether that was
a consequence of the prior build up in
volume 1 or the vast improvements in
layouts and artwork i felt
hookline and sinker for the material
contained in this section which
is honestly in almost every sense of the
word fantastic
the second half details the events that
unfold after the burning mansion fight
between dio and jojo which
by the way it was awesome with a capital
a this was the very first scene and
action sequence that actually grabbed me
and said
this is my swamp now this clearly isn't
perfect by any means with the side
characters predominantly letting the
side down when it comes to contributing
to various sequences
most notably jonathan's father who in
all honesty is one of the worst realized
characters both in anime and manga
and maybe even fiction for me he is not
a character he is a plot device he has
no relationship with his son besides not
believing in him for honestly
preposterous reasons and we only know
that they love each other because we are
told that they do this annoys me only
because he is the driving force behind
jonathan's motivation in
this second half after he dies
but honestly that's as bad as it gets
for me or well
it's one of the low points for sure
however outside of that the spectacle
that is the burning mansion showdown
between a newly vampiric demon overlord
dio and a highly motivated jonathan is
fantastically framed and when placed
alongside everything that came before
honestly feels fittingly massive in
scope and consequence
i'm telling you as soon as do chopped
off that policeman's head my jaw hit the
floor
and this is as good a place as any to
draw attention to this but the manga
version of this story
is way more awesome visually in my
opinion while the animation for the
anime was standard i guess
some of these drawings in these second
half panels are honestly stunning and
not to mention easy to read through
without much effort at all
and did i mention the gore oh my god the
gore
remember in the anime when dio burned
the dog to death well you actually get
to see the dog burned to death in the
manga
remember when dio makes a mother eat her
own child yes that actually happens theo
just goes yeah
fetus and boom she starts ripping her
son apart in the anime it cuts away and
all you see is her shadow doing the deed
but in the manga in the manga you see
this
i can't stress this enough but the
battles and poses and gruesome antics
that take place during this second half
are more than worth the price of
admission and my god
did they suck me into this story in ways
the anime never did before
so once dear goes bye-bye but not really
jonathan then goes on a quest
to endio's reign of terror to stop him
taking over the world with zombie
vampire monsters to avenge his father
and to learn breath fighting from jojo's
resident wim hof
zeppeli a character i am convinced
exists at least partially to give
jonathan another father figure a real
father figure to fight for once he
eventually dies spoilers by the way
i should also mention at this point
because i feel like people will get mad
if i don't but
speedwagon is here too i guess he's
initially a mugger that jonathan beats
the
jesus out of inspires and then
immediately becomes
lifelong friends with narratively he
serves honestly
no other purpose than to facilitate some
comedy to act as the official
commentator for the entire second half
and to remind us of jonathan joestar's
exact
height and waist down to the centimeter
i have no idea why this is important
but he makes sure to remind us whenever
we need it but this section where
zeppeli comes out of nowhere and acts as
jano's yoda mentor
is actually pretty fun it's a standard
training arc that introduces us to this
universe's magic system known as hammond
and he punches a frog which funnily
enough
is actually a really important aspect to
the story i like this system but i think
the best place to talk about it is
during the fight scenes that present
themselves as jojo
speedwagon and zeppeli make their way
to confront dio the fight scenes this
pirate honestly has some brilliant fight
choreography
and it's here araki's writing and
creativity come to life in a way that's
more proficient than i honestly was
expecting though i did have moments
where i was left scratching my head or a
little disappointed however i will say
that for the vast majority of these
instances
not only do these fight scenes hold up
after 30 years but they really capture a
unique tone in this shonen unlike any
i've seen
there's a level of gruesome agony to a
lot of his work in addition to moments
of classic hero vs villain stuff but
more often than not araki likes to make
you expect
something for you to anticipate a
plotline to go one way and then
completely subvert your expectations
before then leaning into a more
traditional conclusion that feels earned
while also creating a nice contrast with
what came before but
enough blustering let's tackle these
fights jojo versus jack the ripper while
a conventional coming-of-age training
fight zepply and jonathan's outing
against
literally a zombie vampire version of
jack
the ripper was very enjoyable it's a
great training scene that exposes to us
the
viewer a lot of new idiosyncrasies for
the hammond power system we were
initially introduced to earlier in the
story and jack explodes out of a horse
too
if i think back to my very first time
watching this series in the anime one
aspect of the show that i distinctly
remember disliking
or finding boring was that of the
hammond power system and while i still
recognize a number of clear examples
that i disliked regarding said system
for the most part i think my initial
perception of hammond was ill-founded
disconnecting your own bones to reach
further walking on water and punching
through
objects are just a small number of the
abilities you stand to gain when you
harness this breathing technique it's
all pretty insane to look at and from a
visual medium that's exactly what you
want from a technique
however despite my initial impression of
hammond being misguided i'm still not
sure if i actually like hammond or not
within
phantom blood on one hand i like magic
or power systems in these sorts of
stories that have a particular focus on
battles or fight scenes
usually these systems offer a lot in the
way of variety suspense and visual
spectacle but in one moment i will
really like what a rocky has chosen to
do here in foreshadowing possibilities
with the technique
and on the other hand surprisingly thank
glider let's talk about jericho's and
blue for his fight
jonathan joestar and speedwagon versus
tarkus and bluefort
it's around this time you should start
thinking about these fights as dungeons
before the big boss that is dio at the
very end
again it's a simple concept and araki
makes full use of these characters to
communicate their personas even more
i've already discussed the familial
cannibalism but there's also this
section where
dio resurrects some undead knights to
fight on his behalf
tarukus and bluefort with the clear
highlight for me being jojo's
altercation with bluford
while zeppeli is out of commission
jonathan is forced to act on his own
against
easily his biggest obstacle yet now
there are aspects of storytelling that i
love and
over the years i've gotten pretty decent
at picking up the literary breadcrumbs
to see what the writer is thinking and
where the story might be going
i mentioned liking zeppelin punching the
frog demonstrating pretty succinctly to
jojo what haman was capable of i liked
this because it acted as a subtle piece
of foreshadowing much later in the story
as jojo takes out jack the ripper with
that exact same principle
catching i assume some of us off guard
because since we've been exposed to that
ability at the very beginning with
zeppoli we've seen and learned so much
more about hammond and as a result that
might not have come to our mind or the
forefront of our minds despite it
technically being a known option or
mechanic within the technique
and it's that narrative sleight of hand
i'm personally a big fan of
explaining how something works and then
implementing those rules in interesting
and compelling ways
the best example i can think of for the
sleight of hand within the series can be
seen in jojo's battle with bluford when
he falls into the water fighting him at
this point in the story hammond is a
fundamental part of how battles work and
pretty much everything revolves around
it but as he's fighting underwater he
realizes that he can't use his hammond
why because he can't breathe underwater
it's a breathing technique and that
makes complete sense
again it's a really nice narrative
demonstration of araki's chops
especially so early in the series
taking something once thought to be
completely understood and then through
creativity outwits the audience watching
by doing something seldom thought of but
still
feasible however ironically this fight
after jojo liberates blueford from the
spell of dio
also has an example of him breaking the
hammond power system in two
nothing and i mean nothing we know about
hammond suggests that this was possible
this was the instance for me where
hammond crossed the threshold from power
system
to plot device in this moment araki
needed a way for the crew to escape out
of this dire situation he's created
against tarukus and
couldn't think of anything so whoop
surprisingly thank glider but who cares
kid crawls in a hole turrucas crushes
two men into soup with his bare hands
and zeppeli dies it's pretty sad
okay jokes aside i call this jonathan's
real father's death scene
because unlike lord joestar we as an
audience actually get to see jonathan
form a relationship with this character
fostering new talent
and go through hardships with him and in
a blaze of glory zeppeli gives up his
life to inspire jonathan and to infuse
all of his life force and hammond into
jonathan's body making jonathan
super buff and shirtless now anyways now
filled with genuine purpose and a new
posse of
randos for some reason well okay they're
not technically randos but they
definitely came out of nowhere with all
of this now filling the sales of
jonathan
joester he finally starts to feel like
the hero of the story and
one that rivals the level of his adopted
brother and now
lord of the underworld dio deo brando vs
jonathan joster
this fight in theory has two sections
that honestly ends on one emotional note
the likes of which i knew was coming but
had no idea would hit me or affect me as
much as it did
leading up to and during this fight that
takes place in dio's castle the panel
work and overall art direction is
spectacular from top to bottom i've
heard a lot of people say that this
manga has aged poorly but
for the life of me i can't see it as
someone that has made a lot of videos
discussing and criticizing the panel
work of other mangakas that are equally
if not more prolific i can say without
an ounce of uncertainty that i have
enjoyed the paneling in jojo's bizarre
adventure
more than quite a lot of extremely
popular manga out there sporting a
fantastic vintage aesthetic
while also delivering upon some visually
stunning spreads and action sequences
that rival some stuff from dragon ball's
manga which
i consider to be of extremely high
standard now i liked the fight between
dio and jonathan but it honestly goes by
faster than i thought it would with deal
losing his head and the fight coming to
an end quickly thereafter
now this isn't to say that i thought it
was bad or anything far from it i
actually
really liked it but compared to the
fight against the two nights prior i was
expecting something
more and boy did we get more out of the
wreckage of this fight the weird creepy
follower of dio that i totally forgot to
tell you guys about picks up his head
and runs off into the night time passes
and we see jojo get married to his
childhood sweetheart and on this ship
they travel
and we get some truly touching layouts
and exchanges between the two characters
recalling when they first met
all those years ago and for a character
we barely see in this
arc this is a really nice and sweet
scene
that all things considered should have
landed pretty flat but it didn't
and then boom deo head and creepy guy
come out of the shadows
with dio finally revealing that he truly
respects jonathan now which is honestly
a really nice moment not only for dio's
character but their relationship as a
whole
because of this dio now wants jonathan's
body to be his own he won't accept
anyone else's
destruction ensues and in the chaos
jonathan is forced to sacrifice himself
to save his newborn daughter and his
wife and
that aspect of the story is what took me
by surprise i've spoken at length about
the traditional nature of this story and
how
at times it does quite well subvert in
order to bring on a surprise
but to kill off your main character at
the end of this arc is honestly an
incredible move that
had i not seen the anime i would never
have seen this one coming the closing
moments of this arc as the two lovers
share and exchange pleasantries with
each other for the last time
are honestly touching and thus is the
conclusion
to phantom blood now that i finished all
three volumes of phantom blood i
must say that while lacking in subtlety
within many plot points despite having a
bad experience through the anime all
those years ago i can't say i didn't
thoroughly enjoy myself this time around
compared to my experience day one
this arc that gets a lot of criticism
from the public that i totally thought i
would join in with by the way has
honestly surprised me with the level of
polish
and clear passion has gone into making
it now it's certainly not without its
problems
many of which i've shared with you today
they all exist but my experience at
least with the manga of jojo's bizarre
adventure has shown me a beautifully
paneled
subtly sophisticated and exciting story
that oozes with love
style and personality that only a
mangaka like araki could ever hope to
realize on the page
there are so many things about this
story that are wrong that really
when all added together shouldn't work
but somehow
jojo's bizarre adventure manages to pull
it out of the bag
and not only delivers but delivers in an
emphatic
and unapologetically quirky bizarre way
and i loved it however if you thought
this video of phantom blood was
entertaining or enlightening
part two battle tendency is a complete
and total
[Music]
thank you guys for watching the first
episode of my revisit into the wild and
surprisingly enjoyable world
of jojo's bizarre adventure when i did
watch this series years back joseph was
a highlight for me then so i can only
imagine how much i'm going to enjoy him
this time around
wish me luck and i'll see you all next
week when i tackle jojo's bizarre
adventure part two
battle tendency as always i've been
totally not mark
and thank you so much for watching
the museum